we've been cooperating with basically
European governments on all levels
during the last one and a half years and
we're making rapid progress now and
solving the issue more than 50 percent
of European customers have already
received their updates with extremely
higher satisfaction rates from a
consumer perspective and we will be sort
of monitoring the the rest of what's
going on actually to journey to make any
calls on this one we are cooperating
sort with all agencies nor partners in
Europe to come to a final solution but
why is it that the company has paid
billions of dollars of compensation to
American customers but nothing to
customers in Europe obviously a very
differentiated legal environments that
we see in the US and in in Europe but
there's a big technical difference as
well the solutions that we will offer to
our European customers which are fully
approved by the authorities here in
Europe eventually is software updates
that actually put the cars and do sort
of full regulatory environments without
actually negatively impacting fuel in
fuel consumption nor actually the the
emissions of the cars the solution for
the u.s. is completely different it's
going to be hardware and software change
in many cases actually done in two or
three waves so actually it's very tough
to compare these two solutions but don't
European customers deserve compensation
for the potential loss that they may
have suffered on their diesel cars we've
been obviously closely monitoring the
residual values of our cars in the last
year year and a half and there has been
no change that there was noticeable to
diesel cars nor any other Volkswagen car
they stay high in demand we have stable
residual values so there is no tangible
sort of harm caused to our customers you
don't think any lasting damage has been
done to the brand then I think the
customer reaction of last year where the
brand has continued to grow in in sales
terms globally shows that there's a
strong bond and positive bond of our
customers to the Volkswagen brand the
positioning of Volkswagen is being they
say top of volume brand a highly
desirable volume brand so between the
volume brands and the premium brands
I think it has unchanged we will launch
this year a series of new cars
that will reinforce this position going
forward with exciting designs exciting
new technologies very safe cars with new
assistant systems which are really sort
of on top of the development of
automotive industry and we do believe
that we can continue to convince our
customers with convincing products and
designs that will warm their hearts so
the the bond of the consumer to the this
brand has not been been been lost it's
not broken in the last few years a lot
of major european cities have now issued
clamp downs on diesel cars they're
increasing charges on letting the mentor
their cities do you worry tool that
you've contributed to the demonization
of diesel cars obviously the cities and
regulators have to take care of their of
their environment and care diesel
clearly is not the only contributor to
to pollution in inner cities so let's
see what else we can do the commitment
of Volkswagen is to do the best to do
actually to sell clean as possible
diesel engines cleanest possible petrol
engines and invest heavily into electric
only propulsion systems and cars in an
in a few years to come